rescue crews are bringing dozens to
safety in Orlando this morning Adriana
Diaz is on the west side or verlande oh
where those rescues continue this
morning Adriana jeff rescues are still
underway we just saw a truck pull out of
here carrying people now at least a
hundred people have been rescued from
this area the fire chief told us that
this entire intersection was under water
earlier today and he'd at least two
dozen homes
the water was waist-deep first
responders found this puppy in one of
the homes she's a little girl who was
left in a cage alone in a house about to
drown first responders saved her now
there has been destruction throughout
this area an hour north from here in
Indian town Florida a massive sinkhole
is now blocking of community and last
night there was one fatality officials
say a person was killed in a single
vehicle accident they say it's too early
to know whether or not that was storm
related but the roads were extremely
dangerous that's one of the reasons why
the mayor wants everyone to shelter in
place obey the curfew until 6:00 p.m.
tonight unless they hear from officials
that it is safe to go outside Jeff
he's granted thanks very much